paul manafort he's in the house i mean i
mean i didn't just realize that but what
i'm learning about you is uh there's a
lot more to you prior to than when
everyone really full-on knew your name
in 2016. okay so i'm looking at your
essentially your wikipedia page right
here uh my question to you is two-part
question is number one how important is
your reputation to you
my reputation is important to me i'm
writing the book to sort of at least
have an historical record yeah i mean i
realized in the in the moment in 2017
and 18 there was a tsunami against me
and there was no way me trying to put
out anything
was possible plus once i got indicted
they put a gag order on me right so that
i couldn't say a thing even though all
the stories continue to leak and uh and
characterize me so your reputation is
important to you is what i'm
establishing so it says here in the book
it says um it's no exaggeration that
everything most americans think they
know about paul manafort is false so i'm
looking at again your wikipedia here um
essentially nothing is black and white a
lot of gray so you know essentially
there's words at the beginning
power broker political advocate
political consultant political expert
right and then you kind of keep reading
down
and then it says criminal tax fraudster
money launderer scandal so you have all
these things
you know for and against you so my
essential question is
who actually is paul manafort
paul manafort is an american
who has spent his life trying to improve
the political system and
bring democracy into countries around
the world paul manafort has always been
somebody who works with the united
states government's interest overseas
that includes whether they're
republicans or democrats in washington
uh because overseas i grew up with
there's you know politics stops at the
american border and uh
and i spent my life doing that
the paul manafort of 2017-18
is not paul manafort
it's a lie
it was part of a social media
uh
orchestration to define me so that i i i
could
and i get into this in the book so that
i would feel the pressure and give in to
the system and give them up donald trump
which i wouldn't do one because there
was nothing to give up but two because
uh
uh you know i wasn't gonna lie and and
because i wouldn't lie
and because i wouldn't uh
uh concede to what was i considered to
be
a a cabal against me
the uh i went to jail and i suffered and
the parts of that wikipedia that you're
reading were written by people who were
some of whom were paid to stand outside
the courtroom holding signs traitor go
back to russia pro-putin things that i
spent my whole life in politics fighting
was now being being used to define me
when i couldn't speak back in the book i
get to speak back it's coming out in
august i'm looking forward to it i'll be
willing to come back here and talk to
you with more of the details of it when
that when it does come out
because i'm not afraid of talking about
my life
i'm not afraid my life is something that
i'm proud of
and and
my book talks about why that is my
father became a republican on a matter
of principle the only republican in his
family he was he was elected as the
working man's mayor it was a blue-collar
tower
new britain was a new blue-collar town
you know stanley works had their first
that's where their headquarters still is
uh
after ball bearings all these there's an
ethnic melting pot and irish italian
ukrainians armenians uh you know and i
grew up where
you know you you lived by your you
played sports you went to school you
lived by your brains and you chose your
careers by your interests and that's the
american dream
and i lived it my father
uh
my family company is a good example of
that uh which i chose not to get
involved in in the end but my
grandfather in 1919 with 10 years old
came over to from italy
sent over by himself had to be picked up
in new york
and he created in 19 i mean he keep
moving before 1990 but in 1919 he
created with one pickaxe on the shovel
uh a demolition company that would with
one employee they went they would take
down buildings and the salvage was what
they made their money on uh
we're in the fifth generation of the
family business now it's one of the
largest
uh uh nuclear nuclear plant dec
i guess
it's not demolishing but to deconstruct
it uh worldwide uh it's it and uh it's
it's i think the biggest family-owned
business in connecticut now um
they live the american dream too each
generation that uh of my family and
one of the reasons i felt donald trump
could win in 2016 is my cousins are not
are not political they're businessmen
and many of them still haven't gone to
college i mean they're they're the fifth
generation is but uh the fourth
generation but they they were the fabric
of our country
and they were all for donald trump and
they were calling me saying what do you
know about donald trump
they've never called me in my political
career asked me about a candidate
running for president it was a signal to
me what i already felt but it was
confirmation that trump was onto
something
that when you got out of washington
was existed in the country
ronald reagan understood the united
states very well he understood it
because
when he was the spokesman for ge and the
and their weekly television program uh
he would travel to all the ge plants
around the country which were not in the
main the capital getting they paid a
million to do that eventually they fired
him because they said you're talking too
much about america but the point is he
was not going to the capitals yeah
because the plants were in the secondary
cities and in suburbs but he got to
understand the country and the reason he
was such and i think some of my
treasured moments when when i traveled
with him the reason he was so confident
what he was talking about was because
what he had learned about the american
people powerful donald trump was the
same way
donald trump threw the apprentice
different with the same kind of
connections made those connections with
the american people and and i saw it
firsthand when i would travel with trump
just like i saw it firsthand with reagan
well that's who i am i'm that kind of
that person and i came to washington to
help re to make a career i'm
representing that mo that that
and to try and protect it
that's not in the wikipedia because the
wikipedia is a political document that's
written by the twitter types who spent
all the time trying to define i'll admit
i wasn't a fan of paul manafort in 2016
2017 straight up yeah i don't i'm now
officially a fan well thank you very
much i wouldn't have expected you to be
but i'm glad you are now paul are you a
movie guy
i am favorite movie of all time
i'm i'm assuming it's number two
is it godfather two or no
you know
you're one of my favorite movies
godfather's up in the top five but
there's a there's a movie that i really
like a lot it's a silly movie it's
called michael
and michael is in the movie john
travolta is an angel who comes down
incredible movie yeah and it's a but
it's a movie about hope yeah and about
dreams crazy and that's my that is my
favorite never guess you're going to say
michael i mean most people don't even
know the movie michael they probably
don't but to me
that is my favorite movie of all time
why did you think godfather too no first
of all
you know
if you have any interest of politics
yeah
you you you have to
you have to because
it's all power plays that's all it is
and if to be able to survive the power
plays of
like what you're doing in there
that's not easy especially for four
decades that's a pretty hard thing to do
but i'm gonna compliment you i would not
expect of you to know michael it's a
great movie it's a great movie yeah i'm
good
but but do you think they'll ever change
the laws for a guy like elon musk to be
able to run like a lot to say they're
not going to change that's not going to
happen yeah so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]